The BFG is director Steven Spielberg's
latest film inspired by the children's
novel and it stars a young girl played
by Ruby Barnhill who meets a giant who
whisks her away to giant country this
amazing world in which Giants live and
roam around but the Big Friendly Giant
as she begins to affectionately call him
is actually the runt of his world and
there's some very mean Giants out there
who are out to do no good and she sets
out on a mission to create some unity
with not just her own world but the
giant country as well
if Spielberg is gonna direct a movie no
matter what the story's about if I don't
really have much interest in it I'm
there because this is one of the rare
chances we get nowadays to actually sit
in the theater hearing a new John
Williams score seeing a new Steven
Spielberg movie actually watching a film
created by a true living legend of
filmmaking and while this isn't one of
his best films ever in fact I wouldn't
even say it's one of his best films of
recent years it is a family film that I
think kids are going to grow up loving
the first half of it I thought was very
good as usual Spielberg is excellent at
sustaining awe he is so good at building
sequences that can make you feel like
you're watching something magical and
unbelievable with films like Jurassic
Park Minority Report or even some of his
lesser films like War of the Worlds he
has a great way of making you feel like
you're watching something incredible and
he really does that very well as this
little girl is whisked away to giant
country and sees all these amazing
sights experiencing these humongous
sights through her eyes was really great
to see and not just because of excellent
a plus motion capture work and a really
strong performance by Mark Rylance but
because we're watching these events
unfold through the eyes of someone who
is so imaginative this character played
by Ruby Barnhill who by the way is
fantastic in this movie this is
definitely one of Spielberg's best child
performances in quite some time I would
actually go as far as saying this is the
best work he's had from a child since
maybe Christian Bale and Empire of the
Sun she is amazing with the comedy with
the dramatic aspects
she's a very stubborn and likable
character and by far she was more the
most entertaining parts of this movie
and actually shine for me above all of
the amazing CGI where the film faltered
for me
was sustaining that AUSA staining that
wonderment in its second act the second
act can get a little bogged down in some
unnecessary sequences there is some very
funny comedy some surprisingly hilarious
gross-out comedy that really had me
rolling I have to reiterate though the
motion capture work in 3d is really
strong here obviously technically this
is an excellent production it's a
Spielberg movie Williams music is
beautiful to listen to as usual it's
just that that second half did lose some
steam for me and despite the fact the
performances were very good the
villainous characters were very
stereotypical one-dimensional giants who
just wanted to pick on everybody it's
just that towards the end it did feel
kind of broken up but I gotta say kids
who grow up watching this movie today
will probably love it and in the future
they'll watch it again just like I
watched hook as a kid Spielberg is still
making movies for families and that's
awesome and extremely important I'm
going to give The BFG a be guys thank
you so much as always for watching I'm
starting a new series of reviews for the
Bourne trilogy I'm going to have the
Bourne Identity for you this weekend you
guys are the best thank you again for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes